Hey, what's up guys today? I'm here with Ty from the Moto Loco Workshop
He came down from Arizona, and he brought me a special gift. What did you bring?
I brought some Arizona bark scorpion these little scorpions are really tiny but the venom that they inject when they sting you is so
Powerful that it will cause severe pain [and] adults for up to three days people who have been stung relate the experience
To an electrical jolt most people in Arizona get stung at least once in their lifetime [with] this one
I [heard] probably one of the most poisonous ones in America
[man] over to my friend's house caught about a jar full of them and brought him over
He's got them on ice and why is that?
[oh] like kind of hibernate during the [wintertime], and I've seen him come back alive after three months in the freezer
[I] don't know man these guys look pretty knocked out you think we can get [them] to come back to life
[I] hope so there is like no movement whatsoever
[still] pretty cold for now [all] right so check this out guys. We got one of these scorpions out on a plate and
Hopefully, it doesn't spring back to life on us while we're working with them, but ty's got a UV flashlight here
And you can see if you shine the flashlight onto the scorpion you can see he just starts to glow that is so cool
And apparently all scorpions [or] [at] least most of them will have [some] kind of a fluorescent
characteristic about them enough to creepy
Oh will creep me out is he be just like jumped up on your face right now you creep
Yeah, all right there. We go. I'm just [gonna] shove this guy into my hand hopefully he doesn't
Spring to life as I do oh
That is insane. I feel like I'm seeing his leg moving. [I] don't know if that's just like a response from my hand or what?
If I tried to flick them off he could really grab on hard good knee yeah. They've got some pretty good pinchers
they can hold on to the wall pretty good they walk across the ceiling to a
Okay, I'm getting a little bit freaked out. [I] swear. I saw his leg moving
We're gonna add the rest of the family
Actually looks really cool
So there's a cool random fact guys scorpions glow under Uv light so if you live in a really hot desert a area
Where you have scorpion problems, just grab one of these flashlights. Take it out on your [back] [yard] at night and light them up
[oh], dude. That looks so sweet
They'll start glowing when you expose them to [blacklight] or even natural moonlight
And the blue-green glow comes from a substance found in the highland layer
Which is a very thin but super tough coating in a part of the scorpions
exoskeleton called the cuticle nobody really knows why scorpions
Glow the way they do, but because they do it makes it really easy for us to find them
Go out at night when they're really really active and just shine and round and they'll light up and stand out like a sore thumb
Yeah
If you leave any boots outside or really in the garage or anywhere where?
Scorpions can be you want to shake out your pants. Shake out your boots shake out anything you don't want to get stung in
Apparently these things will crawl into like really tight crevices a sixteenth of an inch is all and you'll see the cracks in your walls
The cracks in your doors if they want to be in your house. They will be
They've got some weird little beady eyes on top of your head. You've got some black marks, and maybe some other eyes on the front
It's crazy. I want to light hits them. They [just] they really do glow. It's awesome
Oh, it's kind of scary when you go out there, and they [just] start running across the fence
Oh, yeah
I can imagine if these things were moving if they were a liar they'll be quite the show
They don't seem to notice you unless you move something around [them] so you can get right up on them get a stick a half
Inch away from them and then just get them and that is because scorpions have very bad eyesight and so inside your house
They'll tend to crawl on the walls if you want to catch them in your house
you can put some of those little glue traps down by the walls and
Better chance of catching their guys our scorpions are officially dead. They are not moving
They're not coming back to life so we thought it'd be fun to maybe try one more experiment and put these things in a vacuum
Chamber just to see what would happen to them this guy over here
Just made a vacuum chamber this thing right here, and you can see how to make this on his channel
[it's] not going to hurt him at all right?
They're already dead, but already dead [so] [let's] [flip] and switch fire this thing up and see what happens [to] scorpion in the vacuum chamber
You can see their abdomens are treating but not enough to make them burst
And it kind of makes them a little more creepy all right go ahead and release the pressure
Hey
That right there is a stuff nightmares are made you know we should do is take some these to that glowing dark laser tag
Put them on the wall instead of laser tag arena. He doesn't look much [worse] for wear
I mean other than the fact that he's dead, but how crazy is that?
Looking at the Carpet can't really see anything shine a black light on it boom
If you find one of those in your house it really stands out doesn't it as long as you have a black light?
Have you ever met anybody they got [stunned] by one of these Mm-hmm?
People 70 a girl neighbor told me that his whole leg was numb for a few days
Had people that told me [that] they got stung in the toe and I couldn't feel any other toes for
[yesterday]
My sister-in-law got stolen, and she had to go get an anti-venom shot. Oh really
It was interesting as I move this lighter, and it almost seems like it's got a fluorescent paint on it
I mean it almost doesn't look like it's part of the scorpion at all
It looks like it's just painted on very peculiar the sides don't glow
That's kind of why it looks like it's painted on it
Looks like it's got airbrushed on the top and [bottom] so let's take a look at that flashlight
[tell] me a little about your flashlight where it is this flashlight [was] probably only about $20
And it's got a hundred leds in it down in Arizona
You can pick these up at gas stations an ace hardware really anywhere the bigger ones
They're a little more costly, but these are the ones to get you'll you'll see a scorpion for 20 30 feet away
All right cool guys the fun little experiment we learn something new scorpions under black light will fluoresce not really glow in the dark
Scorpions
But fluorescent scorpions get yourself Uv light you can go out there. You can find them all kill em
All you can protect your family your friends your neighbors. It's almost like Magic
So big thanks to my cousin ty for making the trip out here from Arizona
Is the [Mana] [local] workshop? He does all kinds of cool stuff?
what would do you want to see how this vacuum chamber works and how to assemble one yourself you go check that out on a
His channel the link in the description below [okay]. Thanks for joining us for this video guys
Hope you learn something you'll see the next one. Talk to you then right?
Scorpion woman's wait
you